first class is obviously in the front of
the plan if you crash front of the plane
dies first I want to create an airline
maybe me and Elon can get together put
our big brains together do anti-woke
Airlines where the first class is in the
back of the jet first class dies last on
Elon air why are you getting Elon
involved I want Elon because it's got to
be anti-woke all the flight attendants
are gonna be mad on my Airline first
class dies last wouldn't you buy a
ticket for that one are you worried I
worked harder I want to die last are you
worried at all that coach won't be happy
with this situation less tickets fewer
tickets because pointing out that you
want them to die first listen as long as
I die last I don't give a when they
die when they find out this that this
plane is anti-woke and they get to die
before first class they're going to want
to be a part of it they're going to want
to show off The Bling they're going to
want to do firefest selfies selfie
sticks
Etc